what could be constituted a and which I
have a sharpie my straw all brown now
yellow that means I walk in and right
now I know the old
I came to 1798 6i of amount of blue
cheese or chicken chain and then the
same year I came to town a book came out
called behind the arches by John Love
Touch about the rise of McDonald's and
the first chapter said yes there was a
McDonald brothers and they were salmon
or Dena but there's nothing there and I
knew all about Ray Kroc because we're
calling the company and by 1961 and I'd
never do about the brothers and so I I
did they gave that letter at the time
but the poverty came up for sale 1990 I
jumped and I decided open the museum big
McDonald and Mac McDonald two brothers
came to San Bernardino 1940 and they
opened up McDonald's barbecues Asian
barbecue had a barbecue pit in the back
there the cooked meats 24 hours so the
cooking all night overnight and became a
grind and they were getting older so
they they realized that most of the food
that sound was hamburgers so that's when
they closed and then they decided to
close and reopen as McDonald's hammers
the brothers they did not want teen
hangout they do they want they saw the
fact that all the young kids are being
born with a little you know actually
baby boomers we had the war just
standard me over five years people
selling down so tremendous amount of
babies be more and they saw the future
to see young the kids that the little
kids growing up and so they want to
cater to them and so they and it took it
a years of the day as eventually became
a business place in town again and this
is specialized in the moving the product
Amber's and out and so I stole
hamburgers and cheeseburgers and french
fries and sodas and when the brothers
are open at McDonald's hammers it they
needed specialized equipment for what
they want to so they calo coma Xin shop
the tolmer brothers and there's still
the building and still there if they
worked out and they got them to invent a
portion control dispensers and we have a
prototype of a portion control we have a
patent pending diagrams that they
donated to us and what they did with
their first ones to do Porsche Couture
they wanted one squeeze and exactly I
catch up one squeeze an exact amount of
muster and this and they use that system
all the way up until the ages exact same
the same dispensers and it was
very efficient because because part of
that whenever you cook and in the fast
food they would if they like ketchup
they plan to catch up if they like
mustard extra mustard they didn't like
mostly people s and so we want every
hamburger come out exactly the same so
the way to do that is to have a portion
control the first one to ever do that
and then they even they build with it
when they what they did was cook 20
hamburgers a time instead of one
hamburger so it has many special
spatulas waiting to have some of the
original spatulas that was donated to us
and because of the equipment on the
market at the time was to like duty so
they want everything they need
everything heavy duty to handle mass
production so basically what they did
they customized all the equipment to
suit their needs
go away crock was a Salesman he was
based in Chicago he sold multi mixes
what in the early days when he had sold
shakes you had to put in a mixer you hit
the ice cream put the flavoring in there
and you had to have a mixer so they just
mixed it all up together and they get
the right consistency and then he slowly
called multi mixer so you can't baby it
mixed have one blade or the multi mixer
had eight blades and and so McDonald's
the McDonald brothers were using five or
six or seven machines at one time and
Rayquaza selling all these machines and
he said well he wondered what the heck
what are they doing why this sounds made
me shakes why do you so make my machines
if I could go find out what they're
doing
I could show other people how to do the
same and they all sell more mixers so he
came to San Bernardino unannounced I
think about 1953 he sat across the
street and he just wanted to watch the
business he didn't tell the brothers
he's coming he just said watched a whole
lot she studied lines of people and
great by that time reg was already in
his fifties and and he was searching
he's like a entrepreneur he's searching
for something and he didn't know what it
was and when he saw we saw the lines of
people he instantly he knew this is my
disc's whether searching for my whole
life so we went talk to brothers and he
didn't talked about the multi-mission
business so much talk about letting him
be a franchisee and then so he talked to
me to be a franchisee so he opened his
perspective and displays Illinois and
was very cocky because he is the more
a sales guy he named a McDonald's number
one so that caused a lot of confusion as
a Mattel internet came on whose really
started McDonald's the brothers were
were older and they were making that
money they more on the twilight of the
career business career Ray Kroc even
though he is getting up in age he was he
wanted search for something that to
become leaders legacy and so he wanted
to grow all of America he saw the future
he saw he knew the boomers would be born
and even earlier when Ray Kroc started
to help helping because he became the
master franchisor
and he was subletting those out he would
pick locations by the proximity to
schools or churches because he knew this
where kids will be and so he he was
trying to grow the company trying to
leave the ground trying to network and
the brothers kept fighting them because
they didn't want to be bothered with it
because they're making all his money and
they're Gabriel tees from Ray Kroc
anybody else so it was kind of a little
tension so finally you know Ray Kroc
said he had to buy he knew he had to buy
them out and they had to settle on price
two brothers won 1 million dollars each
after taxes also the when they closed
escrow he's got million dollar check and
it came out to 2.7 million dollars to
cover that other the taxes and then but
the problem was the break when wakelock
was trying to do the deal though the
Brazil the this deal doesn't include the
this property they could use find a name
so Ray Kroc is very very angry so that's
lightning talk about the brothers rest
of life so it's a bitter bitter ending
of the partnership this this is the
birthplace of modern fast foods and
everything revolves McDonald's became
the biggest food company in the world
and it all started right here and I also
be bought if I did buy this property it
would disappear it's already bad bad
that the original two buildings were
torn down last time is 2007 1972 so
what's really remaining is the original
street sign and it's not really restored
yet but it I think it's important to
have the idea that this is where it all
started
it one has a McDonald's story so
something good or bad or something with
a little or even they walking is all I
remember to what I remembered so well
I'm trying to have a little bit
something for everybody